-Hello, and welcome back
to the captain's quarters.
Last week
was an exciting one here
as our beloved/reviled
sea captain
was joined by a new character,
Ira, the Prospect Park duck.
We posted a Twitter poll
asking if you wanted
more duck or less duck, and
"more duck" won in a landslide.
Now if you're wondering what
would have happened this time
had "other" won, you would have
been treated to a friendship
between the sea captain
and a street artist's drawing
of my wife from
when she was a kid.
-Hello, little girl!
-Wait, what is this?
-A bit that's gone on too long!
-But the duck won, so expect to
hear a good deal more from him.
Hey, how was your weekend?
-Hey, not great.
A lady in the park yelled at me
for not wearing a mask,
and I was like, "Excuse me,
have you ever tried getting
one of those over a bill?"
Look, it's a stressful time, but
let's try to be nice, okay?
-Well, that's good advice.
-Not to mention, I went to
dinner the other night,
and get this, during the entree,
I said,
"Does anyone know if these
pellets are gluten free?"
And everybody looked at me
like I was crazy.
It's like, oh, I'm sorry.
I happen to have a very delicate
system, okay? Quack!
-Oh, this guy is brutal!
-And speaking of brutal...
-Double team segue!
...the president announced
a bunch of meaningless
and blatantly unconstitutional
executive orders
in a PR stunt
at his golf course.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
This weekend really distilled
just how desperate
President Trump is
as he continues to trail
Joe Biden in the polls.
He announced a bunch
of empty executive orders
at his golf course instead
of negotiating with Congress.
He said he would permanently cut
the payroll taxes that fund
Social Security and Medicare
if re-elected,
there was a Friday night
massacre at the post office
as part of Trump's
ongoing attempts
to sabotage mail-in voting,
and we found out
that his White House
asked the governor
of South Dakota,
"What's the process
to add additional presidents
to Mount Rushmore?"
You guys know Mount Rushmore,
the thing you saw when you were
7 and then only
in rental car commercials.
And there is no process
because it's not a thing.
It's a national monument.
It's not the wing wall
down at the Wooden Nickel.
[ Gruff voice ] The process is
you've got to eat 100 hot wings
in 10 minutes and you've got
to bring your own picture.
We're not a picture company here
at the Wooden Nickel.
That's like going to a priest
after mass and asking him,
"So what's the process for
adding someone to the trinity?
What if it was like the father,
the son, the holy spirit,
and the Dan?"
Actually, that sounds like
a pretty decent idea
for an early 2000s
screwball comedy
starring Owen Wilson.
[ As Owen Wilson ] I mean,
how can I lead my flock
when I can't even get
my own apartment?
It's weird.
[ Normal voice ] And if even
if there was a process
to get on on Mount Rushmore,
I am pretty sure presiding
over the preventible deaths
of 160,000 Americans
in the worst economic crash
since The Great Depression
would be disqualifying.
That's like asking your boss
at Chipotle
when you're getting your
employee of the month plaque
after you get caught
stirring the guacamole
with your skateboard.
You're never getting it, Brad.
You're never gonna get your name
on a plaque.
Besides, I'm pretty sure
the other presidents
would be weirded out
having Trump next to them.
They would all scooch over to
one side of the mountain
like passengers on the F train
after a dude takes a dump.
"Let's get off at the next stop.
Only 38 blocks to the park."
The only upside of putting Trump
on Mount Rushmore
would be picking
the photo to use
so we could all remember him
accurately.
Would it be this photo of Trump
coming back from his Tulsa rally
looking like he just got fired
from his job
as a door-to-door vacuum
salesman?
Or maybe one of these photos,
where he's screaming
like a rabid possum?
Or how about that one
from the GOP debate
where he looks like he's farting
and getting kicked
in the [bleep]
at the same time?
Did he fart because he got
kicked in the [bleep]
or did he get kicked in
the [bleep] because he farted?
Trump wants to get on
Mount Rushmore,
but first he has to get past
Joe Biden,
who he is trailing badly
in the polls.
And you can tell Trump
is desperate.
Last week, for example, he once
again pretended he was doing
a bunch of official events,
but as always,
turned them into campaign
speeches,
and at one point, Trump,
the twice-divorced
serial adulterer
who doesn't go to church,
thought Second Corinthians
was called "Two Corinthians"
and who probably uses a Bible
to hide his "Playboys"
still said this about
devout Catholic Joe Biden.
-He is going to do things that
nobody ever would ever think
even possible because
he's following
the radical left agenda.
Take away your guns,
destroy your second amendment,
no religion, no anything,
hurt the Bible, hurt God.
He's against God.
He's against guns.
He's against energy,
our kind of energy.
-My God,
why does he always talk like
an injured superhero
in a comic book?
[ As Trump ]
Losing...consciousness.
[ Raspy voice ]
Must stop Luther.
He's...against God.
[ Normal voice ] Trying to make
Trump syntax make sense
is like trying to solve
an ancient Sumerian riddle.
If man can hurt God, then is
he not more powerful than God?
And if man is more powerful
than God,
then would that not mean that
God is man and man is God?
Sounds like a dude who downed
one too many tequila shots
singing John Lennon's "Imagine"
at karaoke.
[ As Trump ]
♪ No religion, no anything ♪
♪ Hurt the Bible, hurt God ♪
[ Normal voice ]
I know that was all out of tune,
but I wanted to make sure we
didn't have to pay publishing.
Also, Biden's against energy?
What are you talking about?
The dude was literally out in
the sun biking over the weekend.
Biden is like one of those
grandpas you worry about
because they're always
doing too much.
Grandpa, it's 6:00 a.m., where
are you going with an axe?
[ Gruff voice ] You can never
have too much firewood, kiddo.
You, on the other hand, have all
the energy of a beanbag chair
low on beans.
So Trump's obviously
very desperate.
On top of being historically
unpopular,
he also had no accomplishment
to tout,
aside from shoveling $2 trillion
worth of tax cuts
into the pockets of big
corporations and the wealthy
claiming it will boost
the economy.
And I just want to say
mission accomplished, bud.
Those crappy little bonuses
companies handed out in 2017
as PR for the corporate tax cut
really came in handy
when 50 million people
lost their jobs
and everyone was racing
to buy toilet paper.
Good news, honey, we can afford
an extra pack of Charmin
thanks that that one-time check
we got three years ago.
If you need me, I'll be in line
at the food bank
for the next six hours.
Even before the pandemic
and economic crash,
Trump had accomplished
very little.
So instead he decided
to start taking credit
for his predecessor's
accomplishments.
For example, Trump has falsely
claimed more than 150 times
that he signed
the Veterans Choice Program
into law even though
it was Barack Obama
who signed it in 2014.
Again, he has repeated this lie,
according to CNN,
more than 150 times, which
is just a level of dedication
of lying that I can't even
comprehend.
He is the Lance Armstrong
of lying,
which is saying a lot
since Lance Armstrong
is also the Lance Armstrong
of lying, and in this election,
Joe Biden is the Lance Armstrong
of biking,
but only because the only other
choice is Donald Trump
who is the Lance Armstrong
of not taking steroids.
And when Trump was asked about
this lie
at his fake news conference
at his New Jersey golf club
over the weekend with
a bunch of his wealthy patrons
cheering him on
in the background,
he got all pissy
and walked away.
-No, no.
You ever heard the word
"obstruction"?
They've obstructed.
Congress has obstructed.
The Democrats have obstructed
people from getting
desperately needed money.
Go ahead, please, right here.
No, no, you are finished.
Go ahead, please.
Please.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go ahead.
Okay, excuse me.
Go ahead, please.
Okay.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just stormed off.
Such a petulant little
man-toddler.
It's like the kid
who loses at Halo
and chucks his controller
across the room.
[ As Trump ]
You gave me the broken one!
I am telling mom!
[ Normal voice ] Also, nothing
says man of the people
like doing a press conference
at your $350,000 a year
private golf club.
[ As Trump ] Every American
who loses their job
will get a free sleeve
of Titleist golf balls.
They are repackaged from ones
we found in the lake.
[ Normal voice ] Trump
is so desperate for affection
he's bringing
his own cheering section
to the press conferences now.
It's like watching a reboot
of "Married With Children."
At the debates with Biden,
he's going to pipe in
his own studio audience.
[ Recorded cheering
and applause ]
So Trump has spent
virtually his entire term
desperately trying to erase
Obama's accomplishments
or take credit for them,
like when Republicans
tried to repeal Obamacare,
including its protections
for pre-existing conditions.
They even filed a brief with
the Supreme Court in June --
June, arguing that Obamacare
must fall,
which will wipe out protections
for people
with pre-existing conditions
in the middle of a pandemic.
And yet as all that was
happening,
Trump has repeatedly and
brazenly lied about his position
on healthcare, saying,
"I was the person who saved
pre-existing conditions
in your healthcare
and I will always protect people
with pre-existing conditions,
always, always, always!"
Yikes, that is a truly psychotic
use of all-caps.
That is an
ex-husband in a Lifetime movie
level of punctuation.
Normally when you get a note
like that,
you realize the person who wrote
is it standing right behind you.
So Trump has spent months
lying about his position
on healthcare, and on Friday.
his psychosis spun so far
out of control,
he actually tried to trick
people into thinking
he was issuing an executive
order protecting
pre-existing conditions, which
is a thing that's already law
thanks to Obamacare,
the law he is currently in court
trying to overturn.
-Over the next two weeks
I will be pursuing
a major executive order
requiring
health insurance companies
to cover
all pre-existing conditions
for all customers.
That's a big thing.
I have always been
very strongly in favor.
We have to cover
pre-existing conditions.
So we will be pursuing
a major executive order
requiring health insurance
companies to cover
all pre-existing conditions
for all of its customers.
-Oh, yeah, what's next?
Are you get to issue
an executive order
requiring New Hampshire
and Vermont
to touch at all times?
[ As Trump ] You two have
to learn to share a border.
[ Normal voice ] This psycho
genuinely thinks he can
just get up in front
of the cameras and repeat things
Obama already did, and people
are gonna believe him.
Next, he's going to announce
he's picking
Joe Biden as his running mate.
[ As Trump ]
It's weird he's attacking me.
We're on the same ticket!
[ Normal voice ] Dude,
no one is going to mistake you
for Barack Obama.
All we have to do is look
at the two of you
with your shirts unbuttoned.
Obama looks like he's in
an episode of "Ballers."
Trump looks like a business ham.
And then on Saturday, Trump
signed a bunch of meaningless
and unconstitutional executive
orders rather than negotiate
with Congress while
tens of millions of Americans
face eviction and go without
much-needed
unemployment benefits.
Take, for example, Trump's claim
that he's supposedly
extending the enhanced
unemployment benefits.
First of all, he is cutting them
from $600 to $400.
Second, he is forcing
cash-strapped states
to pay 25% of that amount,
and if they can't,
then their residents
don't get the money.
And third, even his own economic
advisor Larry Kudlow
didn't seem to know how any
of this will work at all.
-So when will people see
their first checks?
-I don't want to be as specific
as you might hold me to it
as you should, but I think
it's going to be
in a couple of weeks,
and I think it's going to
come to about $1,200 per person.
That's a huge --
-You keep saying
$1,200 per person.
Are you talking about in
addition to the unemployment
that they are already getting?
-Oh, no, that --
-Where does that number
come from?
-I beg your pardon.
The $1,200 will come from
the payroll tax.
It should be 800 bucks.
I beg your pardon. It should
be 800 bucks for the employment.
-$800 or $400?
-No. It should be four --
It should be $800.
If the states step up,
we are prepared to match.
That should come out
$400 Federal, $400 States.
-Okay. We'll move on
because I think this is --
it's not what the president
said, and it's a bit confusing.
-Man, even Dana Bash gave up.
That was like watching her
sort through the menu
at a restaurant with
her grandfather.
You want the chicken?
[ Deep voice ]
No, I want the pollo.
[ Normal voice ]
Pollo means chicken.
[ Deep voice ]
I thought it meant fish.
[ Normal voice ] Pesce is fish.
[ Deep voice ] The actor?
[ Normal voice ] Just bring him
some French fries, please.
How can he not know
what his own policy does?
He sounds like the substitute
math teacher
who spilled coffee
on his lesson plan.
"Okay, everybody,
the answer is $1,200.
No, um, wait, I'm sorry,
it's 8-- Nope.
I think it's $500. It's $5,000."
"Mr. Kudlow, I think it's $400."
"Shut up,
you little snot-nosed punk.
It's 800. Run to the teachers'
lounge and get me another beer."
You are not allowed to drink
beer, Mr. Kudlow.
"Well, don't you just sound
like the superintendent
who fired me from my last job?"
And then there's the executive
order that supposedly extends
the federal eviction moratorium,
which it obviously does not do.
That's a lie.
All you have to do is read it,
which apparently Kudlow
has not done.
-A second key point
was the eviction moratorium.
Because the Democrats rejected
various compromises
at least twice, to my knowledge,
the president felt he had
to take action.
-In fact,
the president doesn't extend
the federal eviction moratorium.
I looked at the executive order.
It doesn't do that.
It simply directs HUD to find
a way to help people
and identify federal funds.
It doesn't include extending
the eviction moratorium.
-Well, look,
that's not entirely true.
I mean, in there...
-"Oh, come on, George.
That's not fair.
If I haven't read it,
you can't either."
It's fun to imagine Kudlow's
aides shuttling in
from interview to interview
watching him make a fool
of himself and then hoping
the next one goes better.
"All right, boss. We have only
one more interview left today."
"Where is it?
Please say Fox News.
"Please, Fox News."
"It's, uh, Axios."
"Oh, damn it. Well, you better
give me some of those
loose papers that are fun to
carry around and hard to read."
And then there's Trump's
fake payroll tax cut.
In reality, all he did
was defer payroll taxes
until the end of the year,
which means a lot of businesses
will save up the money to pay
those taxes when they are due
rather than pass
the savings on to workers.
Trump said if he was re-elected,
he would make the cut permanent,
which is even worse
because payroll taxes
fund Social Security
and Medicare.
So if you cut payroll taxes
without a replacement,
you are cutting Social Security.
And when he was asked about
that last night,
as usual, he just lied.
-What we're doing is we
reimburse through general fund,
not through Social Security.
This will have no impact
on Social Security.
We are going to impact --
we are going to,
through the general fund,
reimburse.
This will have zero impact
on Social Security.
-That's not how it works.
For one thing, only Congress
can appropriate money.
For another, this isn't
one of your businesses.
You can't move money around
to cover your losses.
[ As Trump ] I got it.
We're just gonna move money
from the tax fund
to the casino fund to the
hotel fund to the slush fund
to the porn star fund,
boom, done.
[ Normal voice ]
But how do we pay our taxes?
[ As Trump ]
Oh, that's easy. We don't.
You guys should really --
You should really try
tapping on my head.
It's like silly putty.
[ Normal voice ] Americans
can see through this.
It's trump's usual shtick.
He is desperate and unpopular,
which is why he is signing
empty executive orders
and sabotaging the post office.
He has no accomplishments,
no policies...
-No anything.
This has been "A Closer Look."
And this was the most stressful
one I have done all summer
because my parents were sitting
on a couch watching.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
We've been talking about
City Harvest since COVID began,
and now, more than ever,
they need your help
feeding New York families.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask, we love you.